[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité une pénurie qui
dure à la une de ce journal celle de
certains médicaments une situation qui
incite des pharmacies à produire
elle-même pour satisfaire les besoins de
leur patient reportage de Vosges
télévision dès le début de ce journal et
de la santé des animaux nous en
parlerons aussi dans ce journal la
rédaction de 8 Mont-Blanc nous fera
découvrir un centre hospitalier ultra
moderne réservé aux soins des meilleurs
amis de l'homme
distribuer des graines de fleurs pour
embellir les rues TVR nous dévoilera
l'idée originale d'un village pour
favoriser la pousse de fleurs sur ces
trottoirs une solution vous le verrez
écologique et participative et puis en
fin de journal télé Grenoble nous fera
découvrir un métier d'art celui de
tourneur sur bois une activité et un
savoir-faire devenu une passion pour un
ancien chaudronnier dans l'Isère
maison débute donc ce journal avec cette
pénurie qui dure dans les pharmacies
françaises pandémie de covid-19 et
difficultés d'approvisionnement de
matière première bouleverse depuis des
mois le marché du médicament un contexte
qui pousse des officines à s'adapter et
même à refabriquer certains produits
très demandés alors comment ces
pharmacies s'organisent-elles au
quotidien exemple dans l'une d'entre
elles avec ce reportage de Marie Daniel
rogovitz et d'Hélène le plat pour vos
jeux télévision
Christine gestionnaire des stocks dans
cette pharmacie de Saint-Dié-des-Vosges
recharge dès que possible les rayonnages
ici avec des boîtes d'amoxicilline un
antibiotique dans sa version pour les
enfants amoxicillin en ce moment est
tellement mentant donc
voilà sinon on remplit l'automate au
moins quatre fois par jour amoxicilline
mais aussi paracétamol ou cortisone ces
médicaments se font rares depuis
plusieurs mois la pandémie de covid-19
la pénurie de matière première et une
demande mondiale explique les ruptures
d'approvisionnement depuis la guerre en
Ukraine c'était bien avant depuis le
covid on avait quand même des
difficultés d'approvisionnement sur
beaucoup de molécules notamment on a eu
le doliprane après là on passe sur les
antibiotiques c'est tous les jours de la
rigueur sur les commandes les
médicaments à 80% sont produits en Asie
principalement en Inde et en Chine les
officines françaises ont dû se
réorganiser cette pharmacie fait appel à
des laboratoires sous-traitants français
habilités mais les stocks sont limités
des grossistes fournissent également les
principes actifs à charge pour les
préparatrices patiemment de fabriquer
gélules pommade et sirop couramment
utilisé sur demande hors prescription
médicale on ne délivre pas plus de deux
boîtes de doliprane par personne dans
cette pharmacie ou aucun patient ne
repart sans traitement un arsenal
thérapeutique qui est très important au
niveau des médicaments ce qui nous
permet de modifier facilement une
ordonnance et une bonne une bonne
coopération avec les médecins qui
facilitent vraiment le travail l'offre
de médicaments s'effectue sur un marché
mondialisé qui bénéficie par faux pays
le plus offrant en France les prix
d'achat sont encadrés le gouvernement a
décidé la relocalisation de la
fabrication du paracétamol mais il
faudra encore augmenter la production
pour répondre à la demande et peut-être
les prix de vente
voilà et de la santé des hommes à celles
des animaux dans ce journal direction la
Savoie pour découvrir le fonctionnement
d'un centre hospitalier vétérinaire
situé entre Annecy et Genève
l'établissement permet de soigner les
animaux de compagnie grâce aux meilleurs
technologies médicales de jour comme de
nuit 90 professionnels soignent chien
chat lapin et autres amis de l'homme
reportage sur place de Manon Touati pour
la rédaction de 8 Mont-Blanc
il est presque 20 heures quand un couple
se présente à l'accueil ils ont trouvé
un chat au milieu de la route il n'est
ni pucer ni tatoué
entre deux appels de régulation et là
assiste les médecins dans leurs
auscultations mais aussi leur soins son
travail est essentiel pour le bon
déroulé des prises en charge des fois il
y a des situations où il faut agir
vraiment vite et
pour autant pas se précipiter
garder son sang froid
aimer les animaux
juste à côté un autre chat est aux soins
intensifs pour lui retirer de l'air dans
la cage thoracique romane médecin
vérifie l'état du chat à l'aide d'une
radio
Rex scanner IRM prise de sang les
médecins font face à toutes sortes
d'urgences et sont équipées pour soigner
au mieux les animaux ce chien a été
endormi pour faire un don du sang comme
pour les humains ces interventions
peuvent sauver des vies le reste de la
nuit est ponctué par de nouvelles
arrivées au total 40 animaux sont
hospitalisés le lendemain matin c'est
l'heure des consultations de spécialiste
chirurgien ophtalmologue ou encore
neurologue reçoivent les animaux et pose
le diagnostic
en neurologie en particulier on a besoin
d'avoir des un matériel de pointe c'est
donc un plateau technique avancé il nous
faut l'IRM c'est l'idéal dès que j'ai
besoin d'un avis j'appelle mes collègues
et sur le moment on fait le point eux de
la même manière il m'appelle et on fait
le point les 90 salariés du centre
hospitalier vétérinaire travaille
ensemble pour soigner les animaux 24
heures sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7
soigner les animaux mais aussi et
surtout lutter contre leur maltraitance
en Martinique la Société protectrice des
animaux aussi appelés la SPA organise
des formations pour sensibiliser les
forces de l'ordre à cette nouvelle
problématique sur l'île près d'une
cinquantaine d'infractions ont été
relevées l'an passé précision et image
recueillies par Maxime Le queue pour via
ATV sur place la loi évolue beaucoup à
ce sujet et c'est vrai que nos spa
Martinique parfois on peut tenter
d'appeler des polices municipales etc
non mais moi je peux pas c'est pas mon
c'est pas mon domaine si c'est aussi le
domaine des polices municipales
Manuel Valls c'était la vitesse jeudi
matin de l'émission Face au territoire
sur TV5 Monde l'ancien Premier ministre
est notamment revenu sur la situation
politique du pays écoutez-le le
président est empêché Emmanuel Macron en
ce moment on voit bien qu'il est empêché
quand il va à l'étranger des
manifestants l'interrompt quand il vient
en France il est visite Pendé est-ce que
vous ne pensez pas vous qui l'avez fait
revenir au gouvernement vous avez fait
une erreur à l'époque d'abord je ne vis
pas avec des regrets
et encore moins avec des avec des
remords à l'époque il incarnait et
c'était notre idée avec François
Hollande au fond la nouvelle politique
économique que nous mettions en oeuvre
avec le pacte de croissance le CIC la
baisse le cice pardon la baisse de la
fiscalité pour les entreprises et pour
les les particuliers et donc j'étais un
génie vous rendez compte j'ai découvert
Emmanuel Macron et à partir de là il a
pu faire la carrière politique que nous
connaissons qu'il amené à la présence de
la République je plaisante mais c'est
émission face au territoire avec Manuel
Valls et avoir ou à revoir sur le site
internet de TV5 Monde et des partenaires
de l'émission Ouest-France Nice-Matin
France Antilles 20 minutes la montagne
Centre France et le magazine Le Point
hebdomadaire Le Point justement qui
publie cette semaine une édition
spéciale sur la ville de Toulouse la
ville rose le journal y consacre
notamment tout un dossier pour profiter
des meilleurs adresses de la ville
marché commerçants mais aussi bars et
restaurants vous saurez tout également
sur l'art de vivre local le rugby
évidemment est également mis à l'honneur
dans cette édition spéciale du point à
découvrir chez vos marchands de journaux
fabriquer des vêtements pour se vider
l'esprit connaissez-vous populaire cette
marque de vêtements est la première à
être fabriquée écoutez bien en prison un
projet carcéral pour soutenir
l'insertion des détenus et ce qui
pouvait être au début une échappatoire
est devenue pour certains une passion un
atelier couture en détention à sujet et
signé Laura Dubois pour vie Occitanie
on a vraiment l'impression d'être dans à
l'extérieur on va dire deux fils en
aiguille les t-shirts prennent forme
dans le centre pénitentiaire de Toulouse
face 4 détenus travaillent dans
l'atelier de couture pour populaire une
marque de vêtements qui n'est fabriqué
qu'en milieu carcéral 2 jours par
semaine les prévenus se retrouvent pour
coudre un rendez-vous qui leur permet
d'apprendre et de se sentir un peu plus
libre c'est bien on apprend quelque
chose de nouveau se rendre utile et puis
aider Madame Servière à monter son
entreprise je trouve que c'est
merveilleux le milieu carcéral la
créatrice de la marque Mathilde servièr
le connaît bien ancienne conseillère
pénitentiaire elle a un nouvel objectif
avec la fabrication de ses vêtements
évitez la récidive des détenus et donner
du sens alors séjour en prison cela
commence par des entretiens d'embauche
le détenues sont volontaires dans une
activité il faut savoir aussi que
l'offre est insuffisante par rapport à
la demande depuis mai 2022 les détenus
bénéficient d'un contrat de travail plus
qu'un simple échappatoire chez certains
la couture est même devenue une vocation
j'ai même commandé un livre sur le Berba
de la couture je suis vraiment tombé sur
le charme de ce métier Mathilde Servière
garde espoir de voir un jour un de ses
détenus être embauché à l'extérieur du
centre pénitentiel comme je dis toujours
de leur faire acquérir des compétences
et techniques et sociales voilà comme on
dit on travaille vraiment aussi sur le
lien social sur le rapport à autrui sur
le rapport à l'autorité prochaine
objectif pour populaire réaliser
beaucoup de ventes afin d'embaucher plus
de détenus
voilà une idée innovante qui nous
conduit en Bretagne dans ce journal ou
trois amis se sont associés pour ouvrir
un bar garage un projet étonnant qui a
pour but de dynamiser leur village
reportage dans ce lieu unique en son
genre de Karine Chevrollier pour TBO la
chaîne du groupe Le Télégramme en
Bretagne
ces souvenirs remontent à une dizaine
d'années le barbrasseries de Lignol
avait depuis garder porte close mais il
y a un nom trois amis se lancent pour
lui donner une nouvelle vie on a d'abord
fait pour la commune je pense vraiment
et ça c'est le premier pont on l'a fait
parce qu'on est de l'ignol qu'on se
plaît ici et on a voulu faire ça avec
les gens qui nous ressemblent en fait
dans les milieux ruraux Steven Gaëtan et
Yoann ont entre 26 et 31 ans avant de se
tourner vers la gérance de ce lieu tous
les trois étaient dans l'automobile
c'est donc tout naturellement qu'ils ont
lancé ce barbararage j'aime le commerce
j'aime l'automobile j'aime le contact
avec les gens donc c'est des choses
qu'on retrouve que ce soit au garage ou
même en brasserie où on a plus le temps
d'échanger car dans cette commune de 885
habitants une seule boulangerie le
nouveau commerce a apporté de quoi
recréer du lien social et
intergénérationnels
et on se voit on vient on s'arrête de
temps en temps je crois que les jeunes
issus du milieu rural envie de rester
chez eux ou de revenir je vois pas
pourquoi ça serait moins bien qu'en
ville les trois amis associés ont depuis
embauché un salarié le bienvenu propose
aussi des soirées à thème autour des
cuisines du monde et un café filou
mensuel a vu le jour et si vous deveniez
propriétaire d'une caserne de
gendarmerie l'annonce à de quoi
surprendre elle est pourtant bien
concrète dans l'Aube ou le Département
souhaite vendre les trois bâtiments qui
constituaient une ancienne caserne plus
de 1100 mètres carrés dont la rédaction
de Canal 32 vous propose une petite
visite guidée
en 2020 les gendarmes de
Brienne-le-Château ont investi de
nouveaux locaux plus fonctionnels et
adapté à leurs besoins que l'ancienne
caserne elle est aujourd'hui mise en
vente par le Département c'est une
pratique courante du département lorsque
des biens immobiliers ne sont plus
affectés à leur destination initiale il
contacte déjà les collectivités qui
pourraient être intéressées par
l'acquisition d'un tel bien et puis bien
sûr les bailleurs et dans un deuxième
temps c'est les collectivités les
bailleurs ne sont pas intéressés le bien
est mis en vente c'est le cas
aujourd'hui si tu es avenue Pasteur à
Brienne-le-Château l'ensemble immobilier
comporte trois bâtiments et une cour les
bâtiments datent de la fin des années 50
son des bâtiments qui sont en bon état
alors évidemment pas aux performances
énergétiques d'aujourd'hui l'ensemble du
site fait s'étale sur une superficie de
1987 mètres carrés et l'ensemble de la
surface bâtiment est de 113 7 mètres
carrés le prix minimal de la vente aux
enchères 515.000 euros les premiers
critères de choix sont bien sûr en
priorité l'offre de prix le montant qui
nous sera proposé également les
garanties de financement les personnes
intéressées peuvent visiter les lieux en
contactant le service foncier à noter
que les offres doivent être déposées
avant le mercredi 17 mai à 16h
l'arrivée du printemps s'est bien connue
rime souvent avec jardinage et réveil
floral près de Rennes plus qu'ailleurs
peut-être la perspective des beaux jours
s'inscrit avec le fleurissement des rues
en effet dans ce village l'équipe
municipale s'occupe de la distribution
gratuite de graines de fleurs une
initiative pour embellir mais aussi pour
l'environnement un sujet de la rédaction
de thé vert
l'opération est se présente comme ça on
offre un paquet de graines à nos
concitoyens celles consignes les graines
doivent être semées en bord de mur
visibles du domaine public se fait un
peu de substrat et on sème la graine un
peu d'eau et un peu de soleil
normalement la nature fait fait son
travail c'est parti pour une
distribution en porte-à-porte chez les
habitants de Bazouges-la-Pérouse
comme pourvu on est venu vous déposer
les petites graines c'est ça l'avantage
de ces fleurs là c'est qu'elle ne
demande pas d'entretien fleurir les
façades réduit l'interméabilisation des
sols et régule la température des murs
en été il y a pas de mauvaise plante il
y a pas de mauvaises graines c'est bien
à travers cette opération qu'on voudrait
sensibiliser les gens et qu'il faut
laisser le petit brindel le petit
pissenlit qui qui va garnir tous nos
espaces minéral fleurissons nos rues
permettent aussi d'échanger avec les
habitants bonjour Claudette parce que
moi j'ai toujours quelque chose à dire
pour la mairie alors l'occasion d'aller
les voir et de se faire connaître aussi
depuis le début du mandat nous n'avons
pas eu l'occasion beaucoup de les
rencontrer ils ont apprécié donc ce lien
social moi c'est très fort pour moi il
vous reste encore 15 jours pour profiter
de cette distribution gratuite sur
inscription
voilà une bien belle initiative qui nous
pousse à rester dans les espaces verts à
la découverte cette fois-ci de la tulipe
d'Agen cette espèce protégée à titre
conservatoire vient d'entrer dans sa
phase de floraison autrefois très
présente dans les champs et par celle de
vigne la tulipe d'Agen est désormais
menacé d'extinction heureusement cette
fleur sauvage est encore préservée dans
des étendues exemple en Gironde avec ce
sujet de Télé 7 la chaîne du groupe
sud-ouest
ce terrain si tu as quelques encablures
de Saint-Quentin de baron dans
l'Entre-Deux-Mers en Gironde est un
véritable réservoir pour espèces florale
protégées il contient plus de 1700
bulbes de tulipes d'Agen ils ont été
implantés par la main de l'homme au
début des années 2000 pour sauvegarder
cette fleur rouge sauvage chaque année
le Conservatoire des espaces naturels de
nouvelle-aquitaine les contes au début
du printemps moments où est fleuri
au cours des années pour voir si la
population des espèces enfin surtout de
la tuile d'Agen soit diminue soit
augmente autrefois cette fleur sauvage
poussait naturellement dans les champs
les vergers ou les parcelles de vigne la
mécanisation galopante des techniques
agricoles et l'utilisation d'engrais ou
de pesticides ont eu raison de sa
prolifération naturelle la tulipe d'Agen
est capricieuse d'année en année des
spécimens implantées ici ne fleurissent
pas tous et pas forcément en même temps
ce caprice n'a pour le moment pas
d'explication scientifique étayée a
priori il y a des phénomènes météo qui
influencent les taux de floraison de la
tulipe d'Agen
probablement des des quantités de de
d'eau tombé pendant l'hiver peut-être
dans l'ensoleillement pendant l'hiver
etc les promeneurs équipés d'appareils
photos ne s'y sont pas trompés boitiers
dans la main bague macro dans l'autre il
tente d'immortaliser cette floraison
éphémère très agréable à photographier
pas facile le cœur est assez refermé
elle est très belle j'ai posé un genre
de congé pour venir les observer la
cueillette de cette tulipe d'Agen ou
l'arrachage de son bulbe est strictement
interdit depuis 1995 cette fleur rouge
sauvage fait l'objet de mesures de
protection au titre des espèces menacées
d'extinctions vouloir ramener une fleur
ou un bulbe chez soi constitue un débit
passible de 9000 euros d'amende et de 6
mois d'emprisonnement
intéressons-nous maintenant à un sport
au programme des Jeux olympiques de
Paris et pourtant méconnu dans sa
pratique professionnelle le BMX un sport
d'impulsion qui consiste à parcourir en
un minimum de temps une piste composée
de bosses et de virages très relevés à
Limoges le club local organise
régulièrement des initiations en
direction des collèges objectif séduire
et faire découvrir sur place à l'undruot
pour cet à Limoges
le BMX sport olympique mais sport encore
mal ou peu connu le Club de Limoges doté
d'un des plus beaux circuits du
Sud-Ouest son poids à le faire découvrir
au plus jeune et cette fois à
l'initiative d'un pilote du club
collégien de 5e on est classé olympique
et on avait un projet sur une semaine et
en fait il a fait faire un petit
courrier ou toute la classe a signé en
me demandant de faire du BMX j'avais
déjà vu sur internet que le club il
faisait l'initiations et du coup bah
j'ai eu l'idée de le faire équilibre
énergique détente et sécurité avant tout
tout le monde tombe de vélo encore
faut-il être équipé
ou si vous allez rouler parce qu'il y a
des pistes qui sont accessibles comme à
bouvreuil sur les petits pommes tracks
toujours le casque intégral aucune
contrainte particulière on pratique le
BMX on peut le pratiquer à tout âge la
preuve en est c'est que nous on a ouvert
une section pour les les enfants de 4 à
6 ans quel que soit l'âge on peut
arriver légitimement inquiète
et être en situation de prendre une
licence après 45 minutes d'initiation
c'est plus simple que ce que je pensais
que si en fait si on commence pas vite
bah tu vas pas vite sur les potes et ça
s'arrête 21 mai prochain Limoges reçoit
une manche de la Coupe de France avec
des points à prendre pour la sélection
aux JO
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouvrir pour se souvenir en Moselle le
César Palace mythique discothèque des
années 90 et 2000 retrouver le temps
d'une soirée son ambiance nocturne un
bon de 30 ans en arrière pour rappeler
l'esprit unique de cette boîte de nuit
pour l'occasion plus de 1000 fêtards ont
enflammé la piste de danse comme a pu le
constater Emma Facchetti pour Moselle TV
regardez
les débutants
pour cette saison Palace
revivre l'ambiance du César Palace le
temps d'une soirée ces centaines de
nostalgie n'aurait manqué ça pour rien
au monde
[Musique]
ça fait plaisir ça nous rappelle de
super souvenir ça nous rajeunit même si
physiquement pas trop mais mentalement
on a toujours les 18 20 ans de l'époque
quoi il faut dire que de 1991 au début
des années 2000 le César Palace était
une institution dans la région le
légendaire et DJ Fred déjà derrière les
platines à l'époque s'en rappelle comme
si c'était hier ça a marqué toute ma vie
dans la mesure où c'est le club où j'ai
vécu les plus belles choses qui me sont
arrivées dans mon métier de DJ j'ai
commencé ma carrière là bas j'ai vécu
les six plus belles années de toute ma
vie
pour que l'effetard puisse mettre le feu
à la piste 30 ans après le DJ peut
compter sur sa botte secrète
des tubes incontournables des années 90
rythmé par ces mélodies entêtantes les
soirées folles du César Palace ont
marqué à jamais l'esprit d'une
génération discothèque mythique parce
que c'était une des rares discothèques
de Saint-Avold pour leur dernière danse
ces 1000 klubers n'ont pas hésité à se
déhancher sur le dancefloor jusqu'au
petit matin
[Musique]
une toute autre ambiance à présent dans
cette édition bien plus calme cette
fois-ci pour la réouverture du musée
Goya à Castres le lieu fermé durant
trois ans pour travaux accueille de
nouveau du public depuis ce 15 Avril
amusez vous le voyez sur ces images de
nos partenaires de la Dépêche du Midi
qui est rénové et qui abrite désormais
600 œuvres dédiées à la espagnole dont
plusieurs bien sûr du peintre est
graveur Goya écoutez à ce propos la
directrice du musée elle répondait aux
questions de Manon aussi sur place
on a donné une place complètement
différente à Goya qui est vraiment au
cœur du parcours avec la partie dédiée
aux peintures et puis la partie dédiée
aux gravures on a ouvert aussi le
parcours sur la fin du 20e siècle et
puis le début du 21e siècle donc de
manière vraiment à proposer une
traversée historique de cet art espagnol
qui fait la force de ce musée et sa
singularité totale puisque nous sommes
le seul musée français à représenter de
cette façon là de façon
quasi-mexhaustive l'art espagnol du
Moyen-Âge jusqu'à nos jours
et puis si ce musée Goya était
entièrement modernisé il ne sait pas
encore robotisé comme dans la Sarthe ou
le musée d'archéologie et d'histoire
locale propose une nouvelle expérience
effectuer sa visite accompagnée d'un
robot Thémis et son nom guide ainsi les
curieux à travers l'histoire un mariage
entre passé et technologique que nous
raconte Enzo Maubert pour LMTv Sarthe
bonjour je suis Teddy le robot guide peu
conventionnel qui vous accompagne
aujourd'hui ce petit robot ou sourire
taquin est l'un des nouveaux guides du
musée Jean-Claude Boulard au Mans pour
lui dire bonjour rien de plus simple
vous tapotez sur son écran et il vous
emmène en visite
l'objectif de ce robot c'est d'apporter
une touche d'originalité et un
complément à la visite en ajoutant des
images des vidéos des textes en faisant
des zooms sur les objets donc ils mettra
en valeur principalement le trésor de
cowford qui est un des ensembles
d'argenterie les plus importants qu'on a
dans les musées de France et puis des
objets plus quotidiens et plus usuels
comme des clés des pièces de monnaie ou
des matrices de saut aujourd'hui on
pourrait faire le terme de dépôt
monétaire le projet a été développé par
deux étudiantes de l'Université du Mans
et l'entreprise mancelle saint bioïde
qui développe des applications pour
robot grâce à son radar intégré Thémis
est capable de se déplacer en toute
autonomie il la pièce il a repéré les
obstacles il a repéré les vitrines il a
repéré un petit peu tous les éléments
qui allaient lui permettre de de passe
ou passer ou comment se déplacer etc et
ensuite les les étudiants ont juste
positionner des points d'intérêt
orienter le robot à chaque point
d'intérêt de façon à ce qu'il puisse
être présent dans une situation toujours
face au public le robot est pour
l'instant en face de test pendant 2 mois
si l'essai est concluant t'ai mis pourra
peut-être devenir officiellement guide
des musées du Mans allez on referme ce
journal à la découverte un savoir-faire
celui de tourneur sur bois une activité
qui a décidé d'embrasser il y a 10 ans
un ancien chaudronnier dans l'Isère au
cœur de son atelier le bois devient
œuvre d'art et sa passion une
transmission Mirco petchi pour
telegrenoble
les yeux fixés et le geste précis
Jacques esterméant ancien chaudronnier
et tourneur d'art sur bois depuis 10 ans
à l'aide d'un tour il creuse il affine
et forme des rondins de bois pour
extraire des oeuvres d'art un patient du
bois au départ c'était pour faire des
petits leurres de pêche et puis ça s'est
vite transformé en si vraiment magique
qu'est-ce que je peux faire de plus et
de mieux donc j'ai fait des formations
en basique et maintenant ce supportateur
sa rencontre avec le tourneur d'art à la
Meillant il y a 8 ans à influencer son
style aujourd'hui à la retraite il crée
dans son atelier à
Saint-Nizier-du-Moucherotte il y a
beaucoup de rigueur à avoir quand on
tourne c'est une concentration
permanente on oublie tous les problèmes
de la journée quand on a fait du
tournage parce que on est complètement
absorbé aspiré par le par les formes et
le copeaux quoi j'allais dire non
content d'utiliser des outils du
commerce son expérience dans la
chaudronnerie lui permet de créer ses
propres instruments son essence favorite
et l'érable un blanc facile à creuser
qui lui permet de travailler finement
pour ses créations les plus exigeantes
parce qu'il faut trois choses pour faire
une pièce artistique il faut d'abord
l'idée la pièce de bois qui va bien pour
faire l'idée et puis l'envie en se force
pas à faire une pièce si on n'est pas
prêt à la faire sans cesse en quête
d'amélioration il trouve de nouvelles
idées en rencontrant des artistes lors
d'exposition ses conceptions uniques
sont de plus en plus fines de plus en
plus rigoureuse en donnant des
formations il souhaite transmettre son
savoir au curieux voulant apprivoiser
cette matière
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci d'avoir suivi ce grand gîte et des
territoires on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle édition au revoir à
tous
[Musique]